hey youtubers its charlie Happy New Year
so I wanted to start off 2016 right this
is going to be like a crazy Star Wars
Theory video so just careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the force
awakens yet we're just gonna be talking
about some very specific things there is
a new round of the giveaway - it's to
IMAX gift certificates all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so here we go 10
crazy theories about Star Wars The Force
awakens starting with one of the biggest
ones start with Jar Jar so you know of
course going into the movie this is one
of the bigger theories but coming out of
the movie it seemed like everybody
thought that Snoke was going to be
someone else I think the reason it
caught so much fire is because one you
know it just sounded so ridiculous that
it was amazing and it overshadowed
everything the Emperor was doing in the
original trilogy if you have no idea
what the theory is it's exactly what it
sounds like it just states that Jar Jar
Binks was a Sith Lord the whole time so
all of the buffoonery was just part of
his act to deceive the Jedi Anakin
Skywalker turns to the dark side the
Empire takes over everything in that
theory states that Darth Jar Jar was
behind it all
so of course it's pretty fantastical and
therefore probably not true but like I
said the most damning evidence against
it is the next big theory that Supreme
Leader Snoke who predates the Emperor is
secretly Darth Plagueis the person that
Palpatine referenced to Anakin Skywalker
as being the Sith Lord that found a way
to cheat death now the thing about this
is it's slightly more likely than the
Darth Jar Jar theory but I also don't
think it's true because JJ Abrams for
the most part he didn't throw out the
prequel material but he also kind of
said he stepped around them when mining
material for Episode seven he brooms
kind of described episode 7 as like a
love letter to episodes 4 and 5 while
laying the groundwork for this new
trilogy you know for future filmmakers
and episodes 8 and 9 to do completely
new things so while he didn't take a
dump on the prequels he you know he also
said that he really didn't do anything
from the prequels so Plagueis for me is
just kind of like expanded universe
material where it's like you know it's
very interesting to read about but I
don't think that it's going to have a
lot of influence over what's going on in
the new trilogy now if you go back and
re-watch episode 7 there is a music cue
for supreme leader snoke scenes that's
very similar to the Darth Plagueis scene
from episode 3 so you know you could say
well oh they're trying to mirror this
well I really think it's just meant to
mirror Emperor Palpatine with Supreme
Leader Snoke like they're both the big
villains of those trilogies so Snoke is
like the Palpatine of the new trilogy
but that doesn't necessarily imply any
kind of relationship which leads me to
my next big theory the Sith are
completely gone in the new trilogy and
they have been supplanted by the Knights
of Ren as the evil organization that
uses the force now this is where we're
getting into the books based on the new
trilogy now there is a novelization of
the movie that includes a whole lot of
details that just didn't make it into
the movie things that they cut out
scenes that they didn't end up shooting
but they're all canon there is a cross
sections book that does breakdowns of a
lot of the characters kylo Ren has a
really bad relationship with his father
who doesn't live up to all the standards
that he heard about during the rebellion
against the Empire so naturally like all
emo teens he seeks a new father figure
which is where snow comes in helps to
turn into the dark side eventually kylo
Ren ascends to the Knights of Ren and
kills the rest of the Jedi at Luke
Skywalker's new academy that's really
what this scene is right here like the
moment that he kills all those other
people based on what the books say the
reason that Snoke is so interested in
kylo Ren is because he's a fallen Jedi
from the light side and feels like he
could be a more powerful force user
because he can harness both the dark and
the light now there is some expanded
universe material that gets into this
with Jason's solos character but
remember expanded universe has
absolutely nothing to do with this new
trilogy but the idea is still there so
it seems like JJ Abrams is trying to
push into new territory in his
interpretation of the forest without
really getting into the minutiae in a
bad way like midi-chlorians are trying
to over explain things really he's kind
of laying groundwork for Rian Johnson
and future filmmakers to spell it out a
little bit more so I think what Abrams
did is it he just didn't want to shackle
all the future filmmakers that would
ever end up making films about Star Wars
two Lucas's ideas so he just kind of
laid the groundwork for a lot of new
things to come in so it's like well you
know the force is very complicated and
unknowable in a really broad way so of
course there be different types of
religions that would rise up around it
like we have the Church of the force
which is a bunch of non force users that
really believe in Jedi ideals and then
we have the Knights of Ren which is kind
of like the new sith organization next
big theory this is a fun one especially
if you're big tumblr user poe dameron is
a gay character not
first gay character to ever come into
the Star Wars universe but one of the
first ones that we've seen on screen the
reason that people think this is because
of that scene where he and Finn are
reunited and he like bites his lip and
looks at him there are whole new orders
of religion rising up around this in the
tumblr universe and all I'll say is that
probably what ended up happening when
they were filming this scene is Oscar
Isaac just you know did as he was just
having some fun with the character and
they didn't really spell out whether or
not he's gay before the movie started so
really all you can say is that he's not
not gay so if you're one of those people
that really does want him to be a gay
character then you can always point to
this scene and be like well even if it
wasn't on the page there is truth in the
moment so Oscar Isaac was subconsciously
making him a gay character but if you
also if you don't want him to be gay you
could also point to Oscar Isaac just
messing around on the day just just
having some fun with the character and
not really intending for Poe to be gay
in the literal sense next big theory
Luke Skywalker activated r2 at the end
of the movie that's why he didn't wake
up till the end to show them the rest of
the map now I love the idea that while
Luke Skywalker has been missing in the
galaxy he's been communing with the
force getting more powerful you know
just like obi-wan was when he was
waiting for Luke to grow up but JJ
Abrams has already explained that r2 was
woken up by bb-8 when he rolled up with
his piece of the map and that's why r2
didn't wake up to the end of the movie
next big theory the new Star Wars
prequels are going to reignite the
Mandalorian Canon now if you remember
Boba Fett from the original trilogy he
wore Mandalorian armor but then in the
prequels George Lucas created the Jango
Fett character and that spawned the
clone army and took everything in this
sideways direction now the Mandalorians
are this ancient warrior race that did
end up dying out they kind of deal with
it during the great Sith war comic book
The Dark Horse comic book so you should
definitely check that out it's much
grander much more awesome story than
anything that the prequels dealt with
maybe the new movies are going to
course-correct that a little bit now
there's always gonna be the clones
they're not gonna wreck combat from the
prequels there's even the joke where
it's like maybe we should start using a
clone army general Hux my conditioning
is perfect and that argument just we can
get the clone wars when Han Solo is
walking them up to maz kanata's pirate
castle there is a Mandalorian banner
waving at the top so Mandalorians do
exist in this universe they might still
be alive
might all be extinct who knows but that
is something for Ryan Johnson to explore
or the expanded universe a lot of things
will probably be dealt with in the
novels that don't make it into the movie
next big theory this is going back to
Star Wars rogue one which is coming out
next Christmas Alan Tudyk scare achter
is secretly a young version of lor san
tekka the person at the beginning of
episodes have been played by Max von
Sydow who's very old the age is about
right he would have been alive during
the original trilogy in rogue one is all
about the mission to steal the plans for
the first Death Star so even though that
movie is a spinoff it's mostly going to
deal with things happening in that time
they're going to have to link it to
present-day with some characters with
you know meaning that they're gonna have
to be old characters like Leia's aged
people that were alive that are also in
that movie so it stands to reason that
one of these characters in the spin-off
will appear in the anthology films as a
much older version of themselves in
present-day next big theory how did Maz
Kanata get her hands on Anakin
Skywalker's lightsaber and why had she
been holding onto it for so long without
trying to tell Luke Skywalker give it
back to him or give it to Leia for that
matter well I'm guessing it didn't pass
into her possession until sometime after
Luke Skywalker disappeared so giving it
back to him directly wasn't an option
and we do know that she is force
sensitive like she can sense the force
in Rey that was kind of what that line
was about where she's like I'm no Jedi
but I understand the force so this is
where even though we've thrown out the
expanding universe there are some
similar elements to things that happen
in the expanded universe so what happens
is is during the Thrawn Trilogy there is
a Luke Skywalker clone that is using
Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber so what we
find out is that the emperor has this
secret facility like an underground
vault where he keeps his most precious
items and in that vault is the severed
hand of Luke Skywalker which they used
to clone the new version of him in the
lightsaber that fell down in Cloud City
so in that version of the events the
Emperor sends agents to acquire those
things so I think the new trilogy is
doing something similar where it's like
you know someone who understands what
lightsabers are and how valuable they
are and how valuable this specific
lightsaber is gets their hands on it
through smuggling channels and just you
know puts it in a vault for later
because it's like someone is definitely
gonna come looking for this
but speaking of clones next big crazy
theory Rey is secretly an Anakin clone
and that is why
lightsaber called to her so powerfully
now the force is mysterious and
unknowable in this really grand way so
objects can call to people that aren't
necessarily bound by blood so if your
force sensitive an object that is
associated with the force like a
lightsaber or a holocron can still call
out to you there you know there areas
like the cave on Dagobah which are
strong in the dark side of the force
that can also affect you no matter what
your bloodline is but I swear my
favorite crazy theory right now I
totally don't believe it it's totally
crazy but it's totally amazing that Rey
is secretly an Anakin clone next big
theory slightly more plausible based on
the events of the movie Rey is secretly
Luke Skywalker's daughter and that is
why the lightsaber called out to her in
Y Maz Kanata reference Luke Skywalker
and then you know calling out to his
father Anakin Skywalker as if she were
saying this lightsaber belonged to your
father and his father before him there's
also that line that Mark Hamill
re-recorded from Return of the Jedi for
the Star Wars Episode 7 trailer for one
of the early trailers where he says the
force is strong in my family my father
has it I have it and then it just cuts
off but the rest of the Return of the
Jedi line is when he's speaking to lei
and says you have it was like he's
talking to Ray's character saying that
she is part of his family now in the
strictest of terms I hope they don't
answer this question right away because
it's kind of fun to theorycraft about
especially they're going to mirror some
of the story beats and reveals from the
original trilogy like we didn't learn
about Luke and Leia's relationship till
Return of the Jedi it didn't become
explicit till Yoda talked about the
other Skywalker and then obi-wan
explained to Luke you have a sister and
then a light bulb just turns on over
Luke's head and he's like oh my god it's
Leia Leia is my sister but last big
theory and this is a really crazy one
Rey is secretly the daughter of Supreme
Leader Snoke and that is part of what's
going on with Supreme Leader Snoke
taking Ben you know evil person raises
good characters child to become a dark
side force user light side character
raises dark side force users child to
become a good Jedi now as awesome and
crazy as that is you know part of the
reason why I think that Snoke isn't
directly going after Luke or you know
doesn't want kylo Ren confronting him
directly is because he doesn't want Luke
to turn kylo Ren back to the light side
kylo Ren still feeling the pull of the
light Snoke doesn't want him
to pull a Darth Vader on kylo Ren
they're still good in you I can sense it
Snoke probably wants to sidestep that
entirely but let me know in the comments
what is your favorite crazy theory about
Star Wars Episode seven and remember
like the ones that I picked for this
list they don't necessarily have to be
true just let me know about your
favorite theory that you've heard that
just sounds absolutely crazy what's
gonna happen next is I'm going to post
my Sherlock special video later tonight
it's on PBS if you live in the United
States
Benedict Cumberbatch martin freeman are
amazing they're also both part of the
Marvel Universe now Benedict Cumberbatch
is Doctor Strange Martin Freeman is
going to be in Captain America Civil War
so be sure to check it out my video post
later tonight while you guys wait for
everything to post you can click here
for my daredevil season 2 punish our
electro video that I posted last night
and you can click here to learn all
about the Suicide Squad special that's
happening on the 19th thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight